we did this with the simplest example I
can think oh that's not trivial I
couldn't give me a straight line but you
could read off the gradient of a
straight line without doing a derivative
okay let's really quickly do because I
referred to it let's do X cute what does
it done binomial you'll be fine yeah yes
so you might need a new page way up
trust me X to the 17 all right so we're
just getting X cubed ago now just as we
go through this just a mental image of
what x cubed looks like I drew it before
but it's not a difficult curve to
imagine let's do my first principles
here right the first thing I'm going to
write after f dash is equal to the limit
as H approaches 0 because I want you're
growing the tangent not the seeker right
okay and what's going to happen on the
top it's f of X plus h write x plus h
cubed that's f of X plus h isn't it and
then here is f of X is f of X plus h
there's f of X and you divide by H right
which is that run which is getting
smaller and smaller
okay now don't freak out you've done
Bynum you know how to expand this okay
there's the limit because the graphic
I'll stop I'll stop now
XS h all cubed what are the coefficients
one of which wrong past was triangle on
my after one three three one right so
I'm gonna get one
ok 1 3 3 1 you can see that the powers
of X they climbed down just as the
powers of H climb up this f of X plus 8
and of course I've got f of X taking you
over the end all of that don't forget is
divided through my age now you can see
I've even still gone on the board almost
an identical thing happens on the
numerator of this X cubed up the front
and this is - executes at the back right
and then what you get there all the
terms on the top magically have an H in
them
right sir let's factorize that out H
outside off yep okay now we can cancel
just like we did earlier okay all you
get left with is this
look like nerds and oh man so now I can
actually put in see what happens as H
gets to zero and all of these guys here
because they have HS in them they
vanished away they've become a trivial
right so all you get left with is this
Plus these guys right which of course is
3x squared all right ready you had that
picture in your head of what execute
looks like here it is wow that's lucky
look at the next line my graphs okay
I've got X cute right 3x squared it's
this now what's happening to this well
over here right the derivative this is f
dash the derivative is positive what
does that correspond to for me here
increasing increasing increasing
positive gradient okay then the parabola
the derivative comes down to zero what
does that correspond to
stationary point the gradient is zero at
the origin and then I cry blood just
goes back the way it came and becomes
positive again so positive positive
positive positive positive
I know please don't confuse now this is
a major point ok major major main point
this is f - and this is f ok do you know
what I think that regions before we were
shading so you knew where the graph wait
until one ok so the region that this
goes the sign of this matches the
gradient of this the sign of this
matches the brand of this yeah the sign
of this negative matches the gradient of
this right now people get confused cuz
they look at this and then like what the
that's not that's not positive it's
negative it's below the axis right ah
we're thinking of gradient that's one
plus signs are the grain is decreasing
but it's positive it's positive see that
it's an increasing function going up so
if you test a value here and a value
here the second one will be higher so
it's an increasing function going up
it's slowing down it's slowing down but
it's still positive it's still heading
in that same direction right just like
if I was running and then I slowed down
I'm still going in the same register now
I'm stationed there